معنا الان من كياف السيد ميكولا باستن
استاذ مساعد في جامعه كياف الوطنيه للغات
سيد ميكولا اهلا بك على قناه فانس 2 ك اذا
في الاسابيع
الاخيره سمعنا اصواتا في واشنطن تنتقد
بشكل مبطن القاده الاوكرانيين تنتقد
استراتيجيتهم العسكريه حيث فشلوا في
التقدم كثيرا في الهجوم المضاد اليوم من
كيف وزير الخارجيه الامريكي يثمن ما يقوم
به الاوكرانيين ما الذي نفهمه من ذلك
صباح الخير طبعا توجد هناك اصوات مختلفه
في التقييم
وتقدير نتائج الهجوم الاوكراني وبعضهم
يقولون انه بطيء و لم يحقق اهدافه ولكن من
جانب اخر حتى بين المسؤولين الامريكيين
والقاده العسكريين توجد هناك تقديرات ان
الجيش
الاوكراني حقق شيئا
مستحيل يعني حيث قاموا بالهجوم في ظل
انعدام دعم الطائرات
وصواريخ بعيده
المادى يعني روسيا تتفوق في القوات
الروسيه تتفوق في السماء و مع
ذلك القوات الاوكرانيه لا تزال تتقدم
وتحرر مناطق جديده وا كل ذلك رغم تحصين
شديد جدا
لخطوط الدفاع الروسيه
وتلغيم هناك حقول الغام واسعه جدا جدا و
الجيش الامريكي وجيوش ناتو على سبيل
المثال لا تقوم بمثل هذه العمليات
الهجوميه بدون دعم الطائرات نعم هذا من من
جانب الاوكرانيين لكن من الجانب الامريكي
عام 2024 سيشهد انتخابات رئاسيه ربما يثار
موضوع المساعدات الضخمه الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا في هذه الحمله اليست اداره
بايدن محتاجه
ل لانتصارات اوكرانيه ميدانيه ربما تبرر
هذه المساعدات الضخمه
لها نعم توجد هناك طبعا عوامل داخليه وليس
كلها واضحه
و مفهومه
بشان تصرفات الاداره الامريكيه في
مساله دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا حيث من جانب
تزود امريكا اك الجيش الاكراني باشياء
كثيره لازمه من ذخيره واسلحه ودبابات
و دعم المالي ايضا لازم جدا لاوكرانيا في
هذه الظروف من جانب اخر تطالب اوكرانيا
دائما بارسال الطائرات اف 16 وصواريخ تكنس
وحتى الان لم يتم
ذلك يعني هناك كان من المتوقع ان تكون
وتيره الهجوم
اسرع لو وصلت الطيرات لكانت هناك نجاحات
اكبر مما نشده ولكن نعم مع ذلك توجد هناك
يعني توقعت وامال ان الان مرحله جديده
ومرحله مهمه جدا حيث تمكن الجيش الاكراني
من خرق الخط الرئيسي للدفاعات الروسيه ومن
المتوقع ان تصل الى شاطئ بحر ازوف ربما في
هذه السنه شكرا لك شكرا لك سيد ميكولا
باستن الاستاذ المساعد في جامعه كياف
للوطنيه للغات